obwohl im februar 2015 ein umfangreiches
abkommen in minsk zu dem konflikt in der
ukraine abgeschlossen wurde gehen die
kämpfe an der waffenstillstandslinie im
osten des landes weiter es stellt sich
daher die frage mitte 2017 opel aussicht
auf frieden besteht oder der konflikt
tatsächlich einzufrieren drohte
[Musik]
vielleicht ein kleiner rückblick nach
dem sturz von präsident janukowitsch im
frühjahr 2014 hat russland die halbinsel
krim in besitz genommen und gleich
darauf sind heftige kämpfe in der ost
ukraine ausgebrochen kräfte wollten sie
brustmann anschließen und haben daher
den militärischen krieg gegen kiew
aufgenommen
die annexion der krim hat dazu geführt
dass sanktionen gegen russland verhängt
wurden und der krieg im osten hat dazu
geführt dass man hier einen
verhandlungsprozess den sogenannten
mills prozess initiiert hat heute sind
sie in der situation dass wir eine art
stellungskrieg haben in dem die kämpfe
nach wie vor weiter gehen nicht mehr
filmen intensität wie 2014/15 und auch
geopolitisch haben wir eine art
stellungskrieg ein patt situation weil
keine der wesentlichen konfliktparteien
weder kirch noch die separatisten noch
russland von den bisherigen positionen
abrücken möchte das internationale
krisen management stehen sich in diesem
zusammenhang sei es so schwierig da
erstens gab es keine wirkliche
geschlossene front von internationaler
seite und man konnte sich zweitens die
ja nur für eine mission der osze einigen
750 personen versuchen vor ort die
einhaltung des abkommens zu überwachen
aber eigentlich müsste man sagen zu
beobachten welche gar nicht das mandat
haben hier wirklich zu überwachen und
einzuschreiten von internationaler seite
insbesondere westlicher seite stellt
sich die frage wie man mit den
sanktionen umgeht weil das in die länder
geworden weil nicht zu erwarten ist dass
russland die halbinsel krim in
absehbarer zeit zurück gibt versucht man
daher einen kleinen ausblick könnte man
sagen politisch ist keine wesentliche
dynamik zu erwarten weil offensichtlich
die meisten mit dem status quo zufrieden
sind auch militärisch erwarte keine
wesentliche veränderung weil jede große
offensive von einer seite würde eine
heftige reaktion auf der anderen seite
hervorrufen
die dynamik wird er im humanitären
bereich sein weil eben so viele
leidtragende dieses konfliktes zu
versorgen sind und daher erwarte ich
dass man hier sie von internationaler
seite besonders stark engagieren wird
zurück zur eingangsfrage droht der
konflikt einzufrieren
ich fürchte ja denn viele anzeigen weil
in diese richtung und übergangs wenige
in eine positive